and finally new rule I don't need to
know why Trump fired James Comey I need
to know why everyone else in that
administration still has a job starting
with the man Donald Trump trusts so much
he lets him take out his girlfriend you
know they called you they called Jared
Kushner Trump's Boy Wonder because what
anyone sees in him boy really makes you
wonder what Trump thinks so highly of
his son-in-law he didn't just give him
one important job he came Jared all of
them and so tonight in commemoration of
the one-year anniversary of the day the
world came to an end we thought we'd
introduce a new department here called
checking in on Jared
[Music]
so let's start with what Trump said to
Jared right at the beginning if you
can't produce peace in the Middle East
nobody can yeah because really who
better to earn the trust of the
Palestinians than an Orthodox Jew who
specializes in aggressively acquiring
real estate
but bringing peace to the Middle East
was only the beginning of Jared's
assignments you remember the list
reinventing government renegotiating old
trade deals resetting relations with
Mexico and China and Canada solving the
opioid crisis reimagining the Veterans
Administration rebuilding highways
bridges dams sewers and para lines and
providing broadband internet to everyone
in America and then on Tuesday so let's
check in and see how Jared has done
trade deals
well he's most of the way through
nafta's Wikipedia page reinventing
government yeah that's one way to put it
roads and bridges well we do look better
than we did a year ago but that's just
compared to Puerto Rico
diplomacy with China nothing diplomacy
with Mexico nothing diplomacy with
Canada nothing up well wait well Ivanka
did I [ __ ] the Prime Minister
but basically nothing the White House
Office on innovation doesn't even have a
website you know of all Trump's lies
maybe the most galling is we're gonna
get the best people I know the best
people I want the best people we're
gonna use our smartest and our best
we're gonna get the best people we want
experts our finest people calm down bad
ape we get it bad ape smart tech best
people like Rick Perry and Ben Carson
the lethal weapon of bovine brain eating
disease
Nikki hailey was governor of South
Carolina and of course when you think
South Carolina you think United Nations
so Trump made her our UN Ambassador
where she is now dissing the Iran
nuclear deal because she has a doctorate
in physics I'm sorry did I say doctorate
in physics I met a bachelor's degree in
accounting she got so she could help out
at her mom's clothing shop last week we
met Sam Clovis a right-wing talk radio
host who Trump nominated to be chief
scientist at the Department of
Agriculture despite the fact that he is
not a scientist and his experience with
Agriculture is limited to the mushrooms
growing in the folds of his neck
[Applause]
the new chief at NASA has no science
background either he ran the Air and
Space Museum in Tulsa he doesn't know
how Rockets work he knows how much to
charge for a t-shirt that says I got a
peek at your anus Victoria Barton two
years ago was a bartender now she does
congressional relations for HUD and when
things are slow she cuts up limes she's
working a little in Patton who came to
the attention of drums crack team of
headhunters because she was Eric Trump's
wedding planner now in her defense she
did tell the DJ not to play moni moni
but there's just no rules anymore Sarah
Huckabee Sanders is your boss's niece in
charge of office birthdays but now she's
the spokesperson for the most powerful
man in the world Stephen Miller is the
guy who made every creepy thought you
ever had a thousand times creepier like
when you said let's sneak into the girls
locker room and he said and killed him
[Applause]
his job senior advisor for policy these
are the best people Hot Dog on a Stick
goes through a more vigorous vetting
process
because in Trump world the only
qualification that matters is massaging
his ego you do that and you can get
Trump to do anything just ask these guys